in this specific topic we're taxing the
rich and the topic of tax and duration
people say pat you're rich i don't
dispute it i don't say i'm not that's
also one percent but what i'm saying is
i don't dispute it but here's a
different part so i'm looking at the
commentary one guy's like hey pat just
say it you're rich i'm like who's who's
debating that i'm not who's not debating
that
here's the debate the debate is the
following
the debate is this guy came from a
broken family divorced my out was the
army because i had a 1.8 gpa so jesus
guerra came and recruited me and i was
not a good athlete so i can't get a
full-ride scholarship because i never
disciplined myself to play sports even
though i was in shape even though i was
tall right so i go into the arm i'm
going to do 20 years then i go into 20
years i get a phone call a guy
challenges me named kogan says i think
you can do more when you get out of the
army i said dude i'm not getting out i'm
re-enlisting tomorrow he calls me at
midnight kogan elevation one of my best
friends in the world sweetest guy you've
never met him you'll meet him you'll
love this guy
so
i go to sleep try to go to sleep i wake
up in the morning go to lieutenant
colonel peacocks and i say listen i'm
gonna get out of the army because i'm
gonna go pursue my dreams but thank you
for everything you got me everything he
got that i wanted on my orders he got me
till today i'm looking for lieutenant
colonel peacocks he probably ended up
being a general because the guy was a g
was a leader
i get out i struggle
first business fails second business
fails i tried a personal profit portal
internet sale fails all these things i
do fails i'm working at valleys i quit
my job to try to do a business i'm gonna
get forty nine thousand dollars i go
back to recruiting to say if i go back
into the army what would i get
negotiations come in because there's a
part of it that can pay off your debt if
you sign in for six eight years i'm like
that's great i'll go back into the army
then
i get this one message saying hang in
there see what happens a little bit
longer hang in there a little bit longer
hang in there a little bit longer i hang
in there i applied to get a job at
morgan stanley dean would i apply to 100
different places i was hustling to get a
resume in i eventually got the job they
offered me three jobs i went in without
a four-year degree two-year degree i
hadn't taken a test for three years
because i four years i've gone out i
don't know what it is to take a test for
four years right my brain's not been
working with tests my brain's been
working with push-ups pull-ups you know
all that stuff
i go take the series seven exam i'm
studying day and night i don't know if
i'm gonna pass this i'm taking a test i
press that button you don't know what's
gonna happen morgan fires if you don't
pass the test and when i'm pressing it i
said if i fail i'm re-enlisting to the
army today i swear to god and i press
boom
30-second pause it's a six-hour test
dude i can't even tell you what my exam
was in culver city at the how old were
you with us 21 22 years old wow
uh i take the test december 12th of 01
so couple months after 9 11. result
shows up 78 i said no freaking way 78
[ __ ] i get to keep my job
so i go back and i show to morgan look
you got 70 outside i got 70 percent damn
none of us thought you're gonna get i
said dude
so then i stay i work my ass off my dad
has a heart attack rather than partying
five days a week i put my head into the
books and i started reading a girl the
other night we're having dinner and
everybody's talking about their school
so i went to this school i went to that
school and i'm just enjoying all the
conversations because like oh i got my
mba i got my masters i got my phd i'm
like freaking this is all i'm the last
one this is sick
so what school did you go to i didn't go
to college now come on pat what's
universal i'm telling you i never went
to college i had a 1.0 gpa in high
school community colleges wouldn't
accept me no way
you're too smart to not come on what
college i say i'm telling you i read 2
000 business books and i study topics so
if i chose a topic i bought 20 books on
that topic and i read just that topic
that subject for two months then i went
to the next topic and the next that's
what i did
so some people who want to say the rich
people have these special you know gifts
and all this other stuff i'm sorry you
just don't want to read books you'd much
rather watch netflix so that argument is
i believe anybody can reach their
capacity anybody has that shot but it
takes so much freaking work pain that
not a lot of people want to go through
don't get me wrong life happens to many
different people i'm hitting i'm not
here to judge but all i'm saying is the
system of capitalism
the greatest system in the world that
allows a guy like me
who doesn't have nowhere in my life you
can pinpoint to say this guy was going
to win a lot not one thing you can
pinpoint nothing
not one thing can pinpoint that's why i
believe in capitalism versus my family
believed in communism my family believed
in socialism now i'm like listen just
leave me alone let me see what i can do
if my mark is 50 i'm good i'm happy
because i'm giving my best if my market
pays 75 i'm happy because i'm giving my
best but if i keep bringing value to the
marketplace all of a sudden an
opportunity is going to come up yeah and
you can't predict that opportunity all
of a sudden someone's going to say you
know what
um we can do this project i want you to
be a part of it here's how it's going to
work out freaking boom your name pops
what the hell just happened here because
behind closed doors rather than throwing
the towel you're giving your best
capitalism works
uh it's those who don't work that hit
capitalism unfortunately you did a video
don't say don't work and don't improve
some say i work my ass off but they
don't read books it's those two
criterias
you got to work you got to improve
you've got to have a decent attitude if
you have that capital it's going to
fragile
just the first two just the first two
the first two will land you a good job
you did a video that just came out on
valuetainment it was entitled they will
find you
yep right yep and
i think there's a
some symbolism right there a metaphor
for basically what you're saying and you
saw in the comments because sometimes
you'll read the comments when i'm
feeling
uh like uh uh some s m vibes
um
and they were like uh
pat you're the anomaly you're lucky hell
yeah pat you're the man great to go pat
you got lucky i can't do it i've been
working my ass off fine how do you
grapple with that because you are the
anomaly but that's because you though
because you worked your ass that's not
true though listen nothing about what i
said has to do with my last name nothing
with what i said has to do with the
school i went to nothing with what i
said has to do with certain
you know
god-given nothing with what i said has
to do with that formula is very
transferable to others i don't jump 46
inches my name is now lebron james and i
jump 46 inches i'm not that guy okay
i'm not a
statistician
i can just go through some of the stuff
that stuff and i'm ready no i'm not that
guy it's called work your ass off
okay
and improve
work your ass off i challenge anybody
to do the following
take four subjects
sales negotiation human nature okay
sales negotiation human nature and money
go to amazon i will fund this if
somebody wants to do this you do it you
come back to me nothing changed i'll
fund the whole cost that you had here
four topics read every book on
negotiation above 400 reviews on amazon
that's four plus star
read any book
that's about four star 25 of them 400
reviews on sales
read any book on human nature psychology
persuasion negotia any of that stuff for
sale like how to win friends flying you
know all that stuff then read any book
on money with 400 plus reviews read
principles like things like that by
dalio by buffett
and for two years obsessed over doing
that for two years obsess over doing
that two years later work your ass off
and improve in a marketplace figure out
a way to improve your attitude sometimes
half the battle is people have some
shitty negative unattractive attitudes
they're a crap magnet everything is
shitty everything is complaining
everything is somebody else's fault
nobody is turned on by somebody that
constantly blames somebody else nobody i
go on when i was single i'd go on dates
and i would talk to a girl my last boss
was a jerk my last boss was an [ __ ] i
said out of your last five bosses which
one of them were [ __ ] all of them
i'm like [ __ ] that's not the boss's
problem it's you it ain't no boss's
problem it's your attitude sucks within
an hour you saw the attitude right
you read those four topics two years
work your ass off come back to me two
years from now matter of fact you won't
even come back to me because you forgot
about it because you're killing the
marketplace the market rewards people
who outwork and out improve it's proven
this doesn't mean you're gonna be a
millionaire in two years this doesn't
mean you're gonna be a billionaire in
two years here's what it does mean too
your market value is increasing somebody
may offer you something special next two
years some opportunities come up you go
into a company how many guys you know
work at a company for 50 60 80 000
company starts growing next you know
they're making 100 150 200 next thing
you know they get shares behind closers
they're investing money into a 401k
retirement whatever then 10 years that a
company has an exit this guy gets a 6.8
million dollar check how the hell did
you do it
yeah i think that and you know how many
people have done this by the way
not not 10 000. you know not not a
hundred thousand millions have done this
what you're describing is what education
is before government got involved yeah
so i'm you're you're describing what
college was for hundreds of years you're
describing
you know this the socratic and and plato
playtonian method of education there's
no child left behind thing is less about
educating people and that was bush did
this it's less about educated people and
it's do you show up on time and are you
obedient that's all we care about in
education anymore we don't actually care
about teaching anybody anything this is
why jeff bezos wants all of his
employees to go to college do you show
up on time are you obedient then you
will graduate then you will move on to
another school where you can as long as
you pay money and you show up on time
and you're obedient you'll get your
certificate that says i'm now allowed to
earn money when you're a hundred
thousand dollars in debt when you're a
hundred thousand dollars in debt it
makes you a lot easier to control in
that environment you can't go out and
take the risk that you took when you're
a hundred thousand dollars forty nine
thousand dollars in debt well you're
you're also an alpha you're a hunter
there's a hunter-gatherer issue here you
know i and listen we got a show coming
up where there's a big conversation
between the difference between a
gangster and a racketeer yeah and a
gangster can be a racketeer but a
racketeer can't be a gangster that's the
debate i think hunters can be gatherers
i don't know if gatherers can be hunters
then thomas soul i think said it best i
don't disagree but i will tell you
something i will tell you something in
that part here's the other part you
ready okay
uh do you judge somebody by their
friends
i do yeah okay how do you judge a guy
who's got a girl how do you judge him or
a gal that's got a guy like let's just
say a girl married up or a guy married
up what do you what do you say about
that guy or that gal you must be
something about him i don't know he's
gonna be like you know what good for him
that's what i said legit you're a good
salesperson good for you whatever you
did and you keep them because you know
how sometimes
you know a woman marries up but they
can't keep the guy
and sometimes a man marries up but he
can't keep her the challenge is also
keeping it's not about a one year two
year three year thing we're very quick
to always blame the guy but it's both
people's jobs
it's about keeping anybody can get who
hasn't gotten somebody but can you keep
them right that's the name of the game
seinfeld anyone can take the reservation
but can you hold
the
reservation you have to go to that angle
so going back to it going back to it
here's what i would tell you going back
to it you know what i will say this is
what i would say if you're if you're a
hunter gatherer whatever you may be your
hunter your gatherer whoever you may be
it's your job if you're a gatherer to
team up with a hunter
and if you're a hunter it's your job to
find the right supporters
i'm not sitting here saying everybody is
the same are you kidding me no i'm not
saying everybody's an alpha not at all i
i think there are i don't i think there
are people that are not alpha that are
richer than alphas though because
there's a lot of alphas that have
terrible attitude that cannot coexist
around other people because they keep
getting in their own way i know a lot of
alphas they keep getting in their own
flipping way
sometimes an alpha may need to step back
and say look i get it
i can't win as a one i can't win as a
two but i'm gonna be the sickest
freaking alpha at number four number six
and i'm gonna crush it and gradually i
move up what is the whole purpose of
being number one is that other people
with personalities can coexist if your
ego is so big and you can't keep people
around you that says something about you
not you that says something about the
individual i can't keep you so so we're
on the same page i'm not disagreeing
with you but if you're a gatherer guess
what
if you're a person that's a supporter
and you read those four books those uh
four topics next two years
and then you come to an alpha and you
say you know what patrick i'll tell you
something what's that i read a book and
here's what it said in the book
i'm like [ __ ] i never thought about it
that way yeah it's here let me share
with you hey let me tell you i just read
an article he said this about we should
do this in the company i never thought
about that before
that's that's also now the alpha's like
damn i'm not that good without that guy
[ __ ] i better keep that guy around that
guy knows what the hell he's doing
because i don't know that kind of stuff
so there is a way to always provide
value in the market and the bigger the
bigger thing here is like college to
your point it's almost like an idiot
test at this point you're gonna go
you're gonna spend all this money when
all you need is is your phone and an
internet and you can read everything it
goes back to that good will hunting
thing where it's like what you know i'm
the idiot but you're the guy spending 30
000 a year when all you needed was a
library card at the public library right
it's the same thing now every it's all
on your phone you can get it you you can
pay pay a professor a thousand bucks for
his entire syllabus and do the work
yourself but there's not a lot of auto
diadex out there they won't actually do
the work they won't do it so that's the
part the one is i prefer to put the onus
on me
that's what i always like to do i like
to put the onus on me what could i have
done differently i can't change you yeah
but i can sit there and say what could i
have done so this whole thing about well
screw the ridge screw these guys screw
those guys dude look let me transition
into the amazon story because you
brought it up and i think it has a lot
to do what we're talking about real
quick thomas soul because i think you'll
like this and this goes to what they're
saying you're rich you're rich you're
rich thomas soul has a great quote great
quote about it it's a simple question he
goes what percentage is somebody else's
money do you deserve
what percentage of somebody else's
earnings did do you deserve who's the
actual selfish one here you did nothing
absolutely nothing but because this
person has more than you you think you
deserve some of that like what type of
narcissist are you
that that
i did a video one time titled the
ugliest qualities okay ugliest qualities
one of them was a person that constantly
blames another one is a person that's
constantly entitled another one's a
person that's constantly playing in the
victim game you got the manipulator you
got the divider these are all disgusting
qualities this guy like i'm allergic to
all of that stuff when a person has
those qualities you can't be around me
for too long you're going to hate me
if you have any of those qualities
you're not going to like being around my
presence
because i'm always going to say what
could you have done differently but
you're going to be like what could i
have done do you know what my mom and my
dad did i get it
i can say the same story he's got one of
the craziest father stories he's a
millionaire how did he do it what could
you do differently about it well you
know but it's not like that you don't
know what it is about okay they're not
this one you're right i don't know i'm
not even debating him you're right i
don't know what it is to be in that
situation i don't know anything about
that stuff anyways let me go through
this year what you're saying to to put a
bone that is it's so freaking easy to
come up with an excuse it's so much
harder to look in the mirror and be like
dude
get it to [ __ ] gather like it's on
you at the end of the day and it's just
even easier when you have celebrities
and politicians and people that are
supposed to be our leaders being like
you know what you're right you're right
it is an evil system and the rich are
terrible
oh you're so
they're edifying and codifying these
people that are having these moments of
vulnerability they're gonna stand up
though people gonna stand up people have
to start standing up right now and i'm
not talking about in an [ __ ] way you
don't need to be an [ __ ] to stand up
but people need to stand up and have a
little bit of a backbone can i be a
little bit of an [ __ ] no you can't
because it because then you don't
convert and then the mission isn't
converting because right now the biggest
battle that's going on right now is the
battle of converting who's going to
convert better
it's all about who's going to convert
better what's going to help you to
convert better being an [ __ ] doesn't
convert it just doesn't you can be the
smartest [ __ ] in the world you're not
going to convert nobody that it's what
that's my problem with trump what do you
mean that's your problem with trump he's
not converting people i i think he's i
think he's the people love him and they
also hate him because he's the biggest
[ __ ] in the world yeah i don't i
don't the problem is that he's not
getting the people on the fence to be
like all right i'm gonna go with the ass
but he's a catalyst he's a catalyst
though and he's making people who would
have sat on the sidelines again in the
game no they didn't he just lost
so he lost
yeah you went two whole different angles
we can go there if you want to i don't
mind i think of [ __ ] i think of trump
yeah and again people love him because
he's the [ __ ] half the country do you
have to come here i get it yeah but he's
not converting enough no no
but wait a minute wait a minute
this guy this guy beat hillary clinton
i i
are you kidding me this guy beat
a person with one of the most ridiculous
qualified resumes to go in that
he he's a nobody to beat hillary clinton
donald
trump never been in politics but that's
what they said
even reagan was a governor before reagan
was the president of sag reagan had been
nobody's done what trump's done nobody
by the way you can't put one person pat
i agree with you yeah so that doesn't
mean he's not a freaking [ __ ] i don't
i don't i don't think that more votes or
less votes but he couldn't campaign he
promoted more votes or less votes than
when he beat hillary
well a lot more people voted he got a
lot more votes hey i think the angle to
take is the following here's what i will
tell you about trump's uh biggest
challenge you ready
unnecessary giving birth to unnecessary
enemies for what that ain't gonna stop
for what
why are you giving birth to unnecessary
enemies what's the motive there i
understand go straight like the way he
came up with his campaign we're having
people come across that are rapists that
are fully get it you wanted to have a
blast everybody talks about everybody
invites you to the brilliant strategies
like in aoc using his strategy brilliant
strategy
genius but he created unnecessary
enemies unnecessary enemies when the
topic of discussion takes place here in
florida and i ask who do you want to see
let's just say it's the between desantis
and the republic and then
and trump some camp says trump some
camps say desantis those who say
desantis they say it's the same exact
policies as trump minus
the unnecessary i've said it before i'd
vote for desantis well you said trump
it's it's not i and me versus we and us
that was he he made two major mistakes
he uses i and me instead of we and us
yeah now that was his major major
mistake i alone can fix it he lost me
that i was like you're the guy you're
the you're you're you're the messiah
yeah
it's a the narcissist
you know when a democrat says give me
all your money and i'll change the
weather that that doesn't bother you
yeah who said that that's essentially
what the green new deal is i don't know
give give us 90 okay i'm not a supporter
of the big agreement
i will tell you the flip side of it if
if there is the unnecessary enemies that
are out
to face what's going on today you need
such a strong guy
you need such a strong guy you cannot
have a lightweight guy that's going up
against what's going on today because
it's whoever whatever republican becomes
the president next
it's going to be one of the hardest
positions jobs they're going to destroy
this guy whoever the next they're going
to destroy him
the next guy it's gonna be one of the
toughest jobs to have the next person do
you think there will be a fair election
uh honest to god yes even in the
midterms do you think there will be a
fair election i don't think so because
historically this is this is part of
like when he said he says hey why don't
you become better at stealing again why
don't you become better at manipulating
the game no i don't think there is i
think that's part of uh but i don't
think that's anything new i think that's
been part of election for
250 cameras on it now i just think it's
a little bit more you need more
technology today you need a little bit
more advancement today you need a little
bit more creativity i don't think it's
going to be a fair election no i don't
think it is but i don't think they need
to use that as an excuse to lose i think
they need to be invent like like if
you're going up against patriots and
well they they're watching fine
okay then confuse the [ __ ] out of them
but they have a playbook i don't give a
[ __ ]
don't do the play that you're gonna do
confuse the hell out of them so it
doesn't matter what it is they have your
playbook you still gotta today i went to
the gym in the morning freaking guy man
eat this guy pisses me off because i go
in
when you think about drop set what do
you do you do two plates then you go to
plate and 25 then you go to a plate this
guy does the opposite so i go and i'm
like it's okay hey i want you to do this
a bench with a plate on each side 15
times okay cool
every time i leave my entire body hurts
i'm crying i get in my car i sit there i
cry for like five minutes
i just don't want him to see i'd like to
get a camera on that
so i go in i'm like okay let's do this
15 times i'm like i don't know where
this guy's gonna go he's the most
unpredictable trainer i've ever had
you feel good good let's put some more
weight on it
five second break i'm like no you're
supposed to go he said no no just push
it push it push it and he doesn't say
push it eight times push it 15 times i
can't push it 15 times yes you can't go
so i'm going 10. five more so i'm like
we're done right puts more weight go
this doesn't make any any sense but he's
shocking the body politicians have to be
doing stop shifting blame onto the other
people
i'm just being a little baby right now
but i tell you man i feel amazing
we're happy that you're doing this every
morning amazing so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]